بتاعه تسونامي الجمهوري او مفهوم الهزيمه
الانتخابيه التي كان يعملها الجمهوريون
ديبايدن والحزب الديمقراطي فقط فمع فوز
السيناتور الديمقراطيه الحاليه كافرين
كورتاز ماستو بفارق بسيط على منافسها
الجمهوري ادم لاكاستال همم في نيفادا باتت
الديمقراطيون يمتلكون الاغلبيه بمجلس
الشيوخ وخمسون مقعدا
لديمقراطيين مقابل 49 للجمهوريه فبعدني
بعد كلمه الفصل او الحسن تمسكها ولايه
جورجيا بجوله اعاده انتخاب في السادس منذ
السابر المقبل ولكن ماذا قد تقدم ولايه
جورجيا مقعد جورجيا الذي يميل حاليا
للمرشح الديمقراطي رافاييل وورد وان ذهب
للديمقراطيين ايضا يصبح لهم الاغلبيه ب 51
صوتا وهنا سيحظى الديمقراطيون بميزه
اضافيه في اقرار مشاريع قوانين محدوده وم
للجدل يسمح باجازاتها باغلبيه بسيطه من
الاصوات بدلا من ال 60 صوتا اللازمه لمعظم
القوانين كما سيحافظ بيض على قدره تاكيد
مرشحيه القضائيين وتعييناته الاداريه لكن
في حال ذهب المقعد للمرشح الجمهوري
هيرتشيل ووكر سيصبح مجلس الشيوخ منقصما
منصفا بين الديمقراطيين والجمهوريه حينها
تكسر التعادل نائبه الرئيس
باستخدام صوتها وتقلب النتيجه لصالح حزب
هذه الديمقراطي وبالتالي العوده للمربى
الاول اي الحال قبل انتخابات التجديد
النصفي
[موسيقى]